all right now this is a trial by combat
if I am correct between sir Duncan the
tall of the Kingsguard and Lord
lyonel Baratheon and this is the the
character in white sir Duncan is the
dunk is the character is the dunk of
Duncan again I haven't really told this
story yet so so you know we'll get to it
eventually in like the 7th or 8th Duncan
egg story so he joins the Kingsguard
newsflash
well we kind of knew we kind of knew
that that's that's in the books he's
fighting lyonel Baratheon right that's
the news flash right in his capacity as
the leader of the Kingsguard I see well
I'm not initially but eventually there's
anything where you want to tell us about
that no actually this was one of the
hardest things about putting this book
together what was the question of how
much to tell and how much not to tell
because the readers of course want to
know everything and I knew some things
and you know I'd shared some of them
with my my editor and Grohl and someone
with a Leo Linda but there are things
that I wanted to reveal in later books
in later novels or like in the case of
that in later Duncan egg stories so it
was it was like you know I suggested at
one point like when we were dealing with
one of the big mysteries of the that
people want to know a lot about was
summer home and if summer summer hall
was a Targaryen secondary castle that
was in the sort of the border where the
Stormlands and the reach and the Dornish
marches will come together and it was
home castle two eggs father in the
Duncan eight stories and to some other
Targaryen princess during a certain
period of time but it was destroyed that
at a certain point there been references
to the book something happened at
summerholt something something dark and
traumatic and what exactly happened and
the readers will want to notice and I
know what happened but I don't want to
tell the readers yet because I want to
reveal that in a later Duncan egg story
but how do we get around that because
the maester is writing the history and
this is a very important event so I
suggested that since we're doing this as
the mock fact simile that perhaps mr.
Yan Dale could write a detailed account
and then accidentally knock over his
inkwell and it would be a big blotch on
that page when you when you got to that
book that was my answer here and
actually talked me out of that because
she felt that that if we did that a lot
of customers would be returning to the
book something I got a defective copy
there's a big blotch here I'm taking
three hundred and fourteen could you
give me a copy that has that in you're
not gonna actually find out much about
summerhall in this book sorry to tell
you we didn't do it a blotch but we got
around it another matter but that was
unfortunately my reaction to a lot of
this stuff at whoa wait a minute I don't
want to reveal that I'm gonna use that
in a later Duncan no no you can't tell
them that that's a good detail no no no
bleep that out there from the earlier in
Lindon an ganged up why's that you have
to tell them some of these things so I
did and actually they made up you know
they're there
there's amazing amount of new material
in this book and and stories that I made
up just for the book and stories that I
eventually was going to include the
novel and they've still being the novels
of the Duncan egg story but if you read
this you already know somewhat of what
has happened so there's there's lots of
new stuff in here but I still fix
feelings about telling things like that
do what Sorbara thought and the laughing
norm but I'll get to eventually